President Trump goes on offense after
the mullah reports findings that come
out cory booker has his moments in the
CNN spotlight and joe biden humiliates
himself again i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show prepare thyself for
a blast of anger coming at you very very
shortly because i have something to say
to the British newspaper British
magazine The Economist I will get to
that in just one moment first something
that we all can agree on it's good to
save money and getting the best deal is
important and this is why you ought to
use honey you've probably heard me talk
about honey the amazing free browser
extension that automatically helps me
save money on all my favourite sites but
I wouldn't be doing my job if I didn't
tell you how honey even makes Amazon
better so how could that happen
I mean Amazon's pretty great I love
Amazon well here's how it works with
millions of sellers on Amazon selling
the same products you know you're
getting the best price when you use
Amazon it when you use honey because as
you shop on Amazon honey's best price
finder automatically compares the prices
of millions of sellers that carry the
item that you want I use honey every
time I shop at Amazon I've saved money
in the past month on everything ranging
from a set of weights to various books a
honey is just fantastic it's basically
free money more than 10 million people
are using honey to save money they over
they have over 100,000 five-star reviews
on the Google Chrome store Time magazine
says it's basically free money because
it is next time you are shopping on
Amazon treat yourself to the free
upgrade that guarantees you always get
the absolute best price add honey for
free at join the honey calm slash Ben
that is join honey calm slash Ben you
can add honey to your browser for free
all it does is sit there and save your
money seriously join honey calm slash
man honey is the smart shopping
assistant that helps you save time and
money okay so I will get to the big
national news of the day but first I
need to discuss something the media the
media are that so many of them are just
bad at their jobs
I mean legitimately bad at their jobs so
this week congratulations to you the
readers congratulations to us we are
number one on the New York Times
bestseller list for this the right side
of history we actually knocked Michelle
Obama's book down to number two for the
first time in months because so many of
you went out and bought a copy of the
right side of history this book is all
about how Western civilization was
created the fundamental ideological and
philosophical grounding
of Western civilization it is all about
the eternal truths and immutable
principles that our civilization is
based upon and the book is
extraordinarily anti-racist because if
you listen to the show
you know the show is extraordinarily
anti-racist because if you've read it my
writing you know that my writing is
extraordinarily anti-racist you know
also if you've followed me for more than
30 seconds that I am the Bette noir of
the so-called alt-right the alt-right
movement is a white supremacist white
nationalist white separatist movement in
the United States that essentially
attributes Western civilization to color
they basically make the argument that
Western civilization is great because
it's white people it's not because of
the immutable principles it's not
because it actually has the capacity
Western civilization to integrate people
of various faiths and various
ethnicities and various backgrounds no
it's not because of that it's because of
color and that is the argument of the
alt-right it is disgusting it is unbaked
it is unbaked
decency and it is unbanned philosophy
and I have been ripping the alt-right
for legitimately years at this point my
record on this is not unclear not only
is it not unclear I was the number one
target of the disgusting alt-right in
2016 according to the anti-defamation
league I received a grand total of 40
percent of all hatred directed at Jews
online in 2016 by the alt-right was
directed at me personally because of the
alright I still have security walk me to
shul on Sabbath hey so when people
declare that I am somehow associated
with the alt-right you can tell that
they are completely full of bleep well
that's what the Economist did today
so the economists of course is a major
National Weekly in in Britain and they
did a podcast interview with me on the
podcast interview is actually great if
you go and listen to the podcast
interview it's actually well worth
listening to
there's a lot there the audio was
released last week and I tweeted it out
cuz I thought that the interview was so
good well today in the aftermath of my
book hitting number one on the New York
Times bestseller list the Economist
decided it was time for a little revenge
so they released an article and the
articles title is quote inside the mind
of ben shapiro the alt-right sage
without the rage well they got all of
this wrong all of this wrong because in
fact not only am i not all right now i'm
rageful now i'm pissed off because it's
just a lie and here's the thing the
interview is about the book if they had
read the book they would have realized
that there are multiple references to
the evil of the racist outright multiple
references to it I'm not hiding the ball
here I hate the outright I think that
what they stand for is disgusting and
despicable the notion of ethnic
solidarity that ethnicity alone should
be the basis of tribal affiliation I
find to be repulsive when people say
well yeah but you're a Jew no I care
about religious Judaism I don't care
about ethnic shooties it makes no
difference to me this this alt-right
nonsense is a blot on Western
civilization and I say that in the book
they interviewed me about I say that in
the right side of history this is a
quote from the introduction is talking
about Tana he see coats and Tana he see
coats essentially suggesting that
America is a deeply racist place that we
are divided on the basis of race here is
what I write the photo negative of
coach's perspective comes courtesy of
the racist alt-right movement which
accepts Coates characterization of
American politics but sees things in
Reverse in America overrun by identity
politics of racial minorities the
alt-right loves coats his
characterization of white America is all
powerful as Richard Spencer told New
York Times magazine contributing writer
Thomas Chatterton Williams this is why
I'm actually very confident because
maybe those lefties will be the easiest
ones to flip more than that the
alt-right also sees the world in terms
of a race war one they hope one day to
finally win that is in the introduction
a couple of pages later in the
introduction quote during the election
cycle I was highly critical of both
candidates as a conservative I'd been a
lifelong critic of Hillary Clinton but I
was also highly critical of Donald Trump
thanks to my criticisms of Trump and
thanks to my very public break with
Breitbart news and outlet I believed had
become a propaganda tool for the Trump
campaign I quickly found myself targeted
by a new breed of radical in late March
the execrable milo gianopolous penned a
story at Breitbart openly praising the
alt-right including ODEs to racist
cretins
like Richard Spencer egging on his all
trait followers cheering on their jolly
troller II Milo sent me a picture of a
black baby on the day of my son's birth
that may the point being that I was a
over the course of the 2016
campaign I would become the top
recipients of anti-semitism among Jewish
journalists on the Internet by a huge
margin according to the ADL
approximately 19,000 253 anti-semitic
tweets were directed at journalists
during the August 2015 through July 2016
period
personally received seventy four hundred
of those tweets or 38 percent of the
total hey this is just very these in the
introduction in the introduction you
don't have to read all that far and then
if you skip forward in the book you'll
see that I talked at length about the
alright again I talked at length about
how the alt rights belief system is
disgusting in a section titled I kid you
not the end of progress I write this I
write this racial solidarity among
members of the intersectional coalition
has also driven reverse racial
solidarity from the so called alright a
group of racists who have sought to
promote white pride leaders in this
movement include the execrable Richard
Spencer Jared Taylor and Vox Dei all of
whom use IQ data to explain racial
disparities while claiming that the
roots of Western civilization lie not in
ideas but in race the alt-right remains
a fringe movement but their arguments
have penetrated into more visible
circles thanks to a reactionary tendency
by some on the rights to embrace anyone
who supposedly opposes political
correctness I'm not hiding the ball here
guys I hate the outright they're
disgusting but here's what the here is
what the fools in the mainstream media
have done here is what they it's it's
jackassery of the highest order
they've lumped in people like Dave Rubin
a gay Jewish man and Jordan Peterson an
active opponent of the all right with
the all right they've lumped in me with
the all right they've taken mainstream
conservatives and non conservatives
anyone with heterodox views and they've
said these people are the real problem
these people are the alt-right because
they don't know what alt-right means to
them alright just means right well I'll
give you a hint all right has the prefix
alt in it and it stands for alternative
it was originally coined by actual white
supremacists because it was supposed to
be an alternative right that rejected
the tenets of conservatism this is why I
didn't even make sense when people were
quoting the manifesto of the disgusting
Christ Church shooter to suggest that
conservatives were somehow responsible
the manifesto itself says conservatism
has conserved nothing conservatism has
brought in two basic ideas of individual
liberty and individual rights
conservatism hasn't conserved white
civilization the alt-right makes an
argument that conservatism classical
liberalism that these things are very
bad
that is the argument of the alt-right to
lump me in with those pseudo
intellectual jackasses is the height of
ridiculousness that's what the
economists did and that's what they've
been doing with Jordan Peterson and
that's what they've been doing with
everybody ranging from Sam Harris to
Bill Maher depending on the day
this is insanity I have no respect for
any purportedly journalistic out outfit
I mean so much journalism in journalism
economists I have no respect for anybody
who purports to even pretend to be
journalistic who writes garbage like
that and neither should you
neither should you all this would take
is a rudimentary Google search instead
they decided to go for the click bait
they decided to go for the slander all
because they were just ticked off
presumably that the book sold so well
all because they were just ticked off
that we were number one on the New York
Times bestseller list because again they
tweeted out the audio last week without
any of the slanderous crap but now they
tweeted out with the slander and of
course that's what's getting the clicks
because you come after me and you call
me a racist you're more likely to get
clicks than if you come after me and
suggest that I'm defending Western
civilization okay well I do think that
this does have a linkage to the the more
general left view of Western
civilization as inherently linked to
race as I say in the book one of the big
problems we have right now is that all
of the ties that bind us the ties that
tie us together the things that make us
a civilization together the principles
the immutable principles of the innate
value of the individual the belief that
we have free will that we are
responsible for our own actions that the
universe is an orderly understandable
place and that we have the capacity to
sit and discuss with one another these
concepts which are rooted in both
judeo-christian morality and in Greek
teleology that these very concepts have
fallen under attack and there's a whole
group of people in the West who do see
Western civilization as racial on the
right those come in the form of
alt-right racists and on the left this
comes in the form of people who label
Western civilization itself inherently
bad and the institutions of Western
civilization themselves inherently
racist the idea is that Western
civilization in reality is merely a
pretext when we talk about Western
civilization what we really mean is race
this is how the left gets to the point
where they can lump me in with people
who want to kill me
the left gets there through a quick
trick of logic and I'll explain the
quick trick of logic to you in just one
second first let's talk about your sleep
quality so I will admit I didn't sleep
that great last night but that is not
because of Boleyn branch bull and branch
will ensure that your sleep is better
how well they make the world's best
sheets getting a great night's sleep is
easier and more affordable than you
think you don't need a new expensive
mattress or sleeping pills you just need
to change your sheets that's why you
should check out bowl and branch
everything bowl and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton it means they start
out super soft they get even softer over
time you can buy directly from Boleyn
branch so you are essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand bucks in the store
Boleyn branch sheets only a couple
hundred bucks everyone who tries Boleyn
branch sheets loves them that's why they
have thousands of five-star reviews
Forbes The Wall Street Journal Fast
Company they're all talking about bowl
and branch even three u.s. presidents
sleep on bull and branch sheets shipping
is free you can try them for 30 nights
so if you don't love them send them back
for a refund but you're not gonna want
to send them back my wife and I have
Bolin Brand sheets they're so good we
legitimately took all the other sheets
in our house and threw them out and got
more Boleyn branch sheets because they
honestly they ruin sheets for you
they're that good to get you started
right now my listeners can get 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets at bull and
branch com promo code Ben go to bull and
branch comm today for 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets
that's bol L and branch com promo code
Ben bull and branch com promo code Ben
go check it out right now okay so how do
that how does the left commit this this
trick where suddenly the conservatives
are all alright it's because what they
say is that when people use the term
Western civilization they're inherently
reinforcing a racist hierarchy so when I
speak about generalized principles when
I talk when I write a a 250 page book
about the principles of Western
civilization going all the way back
3,000 years to Sinai and then through
ancient Greece when I do that what I'm
really doing is reinforcing the racial
power hierarchy in the United States and
in the West so anyone who stands up for
Western civilization is in fact in
sophisticated fashion standing up for
this racial power hierarchy now that's a
bunch of crap but you can see that this
mindset has infused a certain element of
the left and that element and left is
unfortunately gaining strength it really
is a threat to the civilization upon
which we stand a great indicator of this
is Joe Biden so Joe Biden was vice
president of the
at states and yes he's a dolt and yes
he's a dollar but Joe Biden said
yesterday that English jurisprudential
culture you know the culture that
brought you equal rights under law that
brought you limited government that
brought you the idea of constitutional
monarchy that brought you the idea of
tort law you know that culture that
culture that basically built the Anglo
sphere that culture is bad it's very bad
in fact it's racist it's white culture
he's saying the same thing in his way as
the alright the alt-right just says
English jurisprudential culture is great
and it's great because white people
created it and now Joe Biden is saying
English jurisprudential culture is bad
and it's bad because white people
created it I realize they get a little
too passionate matters sometimes but we
all have an obligation to do nothing
less than change the culture in this
country that's just the laws we change
the laws change the culture the culture
this is English jurist financial culture
white man's culture it's got to change
it's got to change
it's got to change why does English
jurisprudential culture have to change
apparently in this speech he cited the
so called the so called rule of thumb so
this is a myth Christina Hoff Sommers
has busted this myth there's a myth that
an English jurisprudential law a key
tenant is that a man could beat his wife
with a stick so long as the Thicke was
in the stick was no wider in girth than
his thumb this is a lie it is not true
it can't be found anywhere in the
English legal books there's one judge
who one time wrote about it and was
mercilessly mocked for the rest of his
career as judge thumb in Britain
sometime in the 19th century and yet
somehow this has become a key tenant in
the left's takedown of Western
civilization if you see Western
civilization as predominantly racial
then you are doing it wrong this is true
if you are on the right and it is true
if you are on the left and the fact that
the left agrees with the alt-right on
the nature of Western civilization means
that Western civilization is really in
trouble because if instead of arguing
over principles and the application of
those principles if instead of applying
reason to judeo-christian principle and
coming up with an admixture that makes
all of our lives better you decide let's
just abandon the whole project and
revert to tribalism because hey
everything is power
keys of race anyway things get really
ugly really quickly and this is how the
left can lump everybody in because if
they say everything is tribal then your
tribal too even if you don't know it it
really is disgusting it really is
disgusting
well speaking of differences between
right and left I do want to point out
that the mayor of South Bend Indiana
Pete but a judge I have but a judge I'm
still working on the pronunciation I've
said before that I think he is one of
the smarter people in the Democratic
race I think that is true he seems to be
more soft-spoken than a lot of the other
Democrats he seems to be more reasonable
in a lot of ways for example yesterday
he suggested that he wouldn't boycott
chick-fil-a because he likes their
chicken which seems like a person a
perfectly rational statement but there
are obviously significant differences
between right and left when it comes to
key items of principle and what's
fascinating is to watch as the
Democratic Left tries to hijack the term
freedom to describe a program that is
oxymora that that is that is directly
opposed to freedom in any traditional
sense here's Pete but a judge trying to
explain why his giant government
programs are in fact an element of
freedom freedom from you're not free if
there's a veil of mistrust between you
as a person of color and the officers
who are sworn to keep you safe not free
if your reproductive choices are being
dictated by now hilarious is that in
that video by the judge actually goes
ahead and he talks about how the rights
version of freedom is freedom from how
it the right once is freedom from
government and then he says well but
that's not real freedom you have to have
freedom from your cable company really
from your cable company that's where you
have to have freedom from your cable
company says it's not freedom if you
have job lock if you have to work for a
company because they provide you
benefits that's not freedom really
because it seems to me that you are
making a voluntary dispensation of your
labor in return for someone else's
voluntary dispensation of benefits so
yeah that that would be freedom right
there and then he cites a bunch of stuff
but a judge that his actual government
involvement so he's talking about how
freedom is infringed upon
when officers do racist things right
because armed officers are the arms of
the state so you agree with me on the
definition of freedom mayor but a judge
and then mayor buddy Josh suggests that
it is in violation of freedom if a
county clerk denies you some sort of of
marital license
well it is a denial of freedom in a
certain sense I mean we can argue over
whether that's an isle of freedom is
quote-unquote justified or not we can we
can argue over whether the state ought
to be providing benefits to particular
couples or not that seems like a
rational conversation we can have but if
he's talking about the state cracking
down on voluntary sexual activity that
is consensual in nature then we agree
and we're just both libertarian it's
amazing one of the things that the left
is fond of doing is you see what the
term all right is they define the term
and then they proceed to expand the term
dramatically to include stuff they want
to include so all right starts off as an
actual descriptor of an actual group of
people and then it quickly expands to
include anybody with whom they disagree
and it is the same thing with the word
freedom freedom starts off with a pretty
exact definition which is freedom from
government intervention freedom from the
government
cracking down on you and then they
expand it to include freedom from
anything that you don't want and then
they expand it to include freedom to
take stuff from other people by
gradually expanding the definition of
words they changed the way that people
think folks on the left that is the goal
and you see this in in many areas of
American life you see this with regard
to sex and gender for example so the
left starts off by arguing that gender
is distinct from sex your
self-identification as a man or a woman
is distinct from your biological sex
that is at best an arguable biological
proposition but as a logical proposition
I guess you can make the argument but
then what the left quickly does is they
expand the definition of gender to Rhian
compass biological sex so in other words
you are a biological male and you are a
gendered female according to the left
this means that you are a female in a
biological sense you now have a female
penis and now that doesn't make any
sense but they've expanded the
terminology so as to embrace all that
they wish to embrace playing with words
is a very clever way of doing all of
this and it's it's fascinating you can
always watch by how the terms expand how
the terms expand and contract you can
see where the left moves just by
following the the etymology of the
terminology that they are using
following the history of the words that
they like to use so to go back to that
Biden example for a second save Joe
Biden ripping on English jurisprudence
right it's it's white culture English
jurisprudence I'm old enough to remember
when his former boss Barack Obama
defended anglo-american legal culture in
2006 he said anglo-american legal
culture was quite a good thing but now
the left is demeaning it now
anglo-american culture encompasses
racism weird because it didn't before
when Barack Obama was talking about it
in that speech I spoke about why I love
this country why I love America and what
I believe sets this country apart from
so many other nations in so many eras I
said that the true genius of America is
a faith in simple dreams an insistence
in small miracles that we can tuck our
children tuck in our children at night
and know that they're fed and clothed
and safe from harm that we can say what
we think right what we think without
hearing a sudden knock
on the door he talked about that as a
legacy of anglo-american law he said
that habeas corpus was a perfect example
of anglo-american law now the left has
expands an anglo-american law or English
jurisprudence to mean racism because
they've decided to shift the meaning of
all of this stuff a term that once was
good has now become bad because they've
decided to expand the application of the
term remember that when Pete but a judge
says that the Democrats are the party of
freedom he is talking about the same
party as Bernie Sanders who legitimately
said just yesterday that we should get
rid of all insurance companies in the
United States and robbed some 160
million people of their health insurance
plans you are not going to be able in
the long run to have cost-effective
universal health care unless you change
the system unless you get rid of the
insurance companies unless you stand up
to the greed of the drug companies and
lower prescription drug costs that's the
only way that you could provide quality
care all people I look at healthcare
Chris the same way as I look at public
education right same way a look at
police protection fire protection all
people get it regardless of the income
it is publicly funded that is the most
cost effective way to provide care to
all so freedom is now stealing people's
health insurance away from them taking
it like voluntarily agreed to health
insurance taking it away from them and
anglo-american jurisprudence is now
white culture and alright is now just
conservative you keep expanding terms to
fit what you want them to fit and
language has no meaning we can't have
discussions we can't be reasonable with
each other because you keep shifting the
ground upon which we are standing ok
coming up we're gonna talk about the
latest in the jussie Smollett case
because there are some breaking
developments in that case plus President
Trump going after his enemies going
after his nemesis over the release of
the Mullen report first let's talk about
how you send your packages this year no
one really has time to go to the post
office you're busy you don't have time
for the traffic the parking logging in
your mail and packages which reminds me
last time I went to the post office I
got a parking ticket that I still have
to pay you don't need to do all that
stuff instead you need stamps calm it's
one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps calm
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office
stamps calm brings all
the amazing services of the US Postal
Service directly to your computer
whether you're a small office sending
invoices and online sellers shipping out
products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages today
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is that
simple with stamps comm you get five
cents off every first class stamp and up
to 40% off Priority Mail not to mention
it is a fraction of the cost of these of
those expensive postage meter stamps
kaam is a no-brainer
it saves you time it saves you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses
already use stamps calm right now my
listeners can get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale with no long
term commitment just go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm enter Shapiro for that
special discount four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale in the
long term commitment pretty solid stuff
go check it out right now stamps comm
enter Shapiro we use stamps comm here at
the daily wire offices I personally use
it at home because it is indeed that
good already so the latest on the jussie
Smollett case that case continues to
unfold and we are finding out more and
more about the dramatic malfeasance I
mean serious malfeasance of the state's
attorney's office in Cook County so Fox
the the woman's name is Kim Fox she's
the state's attorney's office ten
minutes ago she confirmed that she did
not actually recuse herself from the
Smollett case legally speaking
apparently her spokeswoman tandra
Simonton said quote the state's attorney
did not formally recuse herself or the
office based on any actual conflict of
interest as a result she did not have to
seek the appointment of a special
prosecutor under the law instead she
simply took her first assistant Jo
maggots out front to take the beating
that would come quote although we used
the term recuse as it relates to state's
attorneys Foxx involvement in the matter
it was a colloquial use of the term
rather than in its legal sense
oh is that what happened there you just
colloquially recused yourself without
recusing yourself you know like actually
recusing yourself yeah that's that's a
little corrupt in fact the break
breaking news I mean the FBI is now
telling local ABC news reporter Rob
elgus that they are reviewing the
circuit
stance is surrounding the dismissal of
the criminal charges against Empire
actor justice Millette remember the guy
who's the victim of the fake hate crime
hilarious left is now out there
defending him I mean like DeRay McKesson
is out there defending him why because
there's the headline that says that the
police put up the two Nigerian brothers
who allegedly beat him up in a hotel for
a night why because they were witnesses
they were cooperating witnesses guys so
is probably that so they're buying
Jessie Smuts argument that presumably
the that he was actually beaten in a
hate crime by two people he was friends
with and called an hour before inside to
check - afterward
it's a weird contention how bad is the
case for justice Millette
his attorney came out and explained that
maybe when Jessie smollett describes his
attackers as white it's because the
Nigerian brothers were wearing white
face I kid you not this is a thing that
was said by a human why did he say that
he could have said I don't know he could
have but this again he's the ocean dye
row brothers what are the chances that
that's the case that he saw somebody
with light skin well you know I mean I
think there's obviously you can disguise
that you could put makeup on there is
actually interestingly enough a video
you know I think police said minimal
investigation in this case it was it
took me all of five minutes to Google
you know I was looking up the brothers
and one of the first videos that showed
up actually was one of the brothers in
white face doing a joker monologue with
white makeup on and so it's not it's not
implausible really it's not implausible
so they put on a white face that's the
suggestion and this is now being
parodied around the internet by people
unless oh that's probably what happened
these and I jurian brothers decided to
commit a hate crime by putting on white
face so they're the hoaxsters not Jesse
Smollett how bad was the handling of
this entire case so bad that the
National Association of District
Attorney's torched Kym Fox yesterday
they put out a statement they said quote
first when a chief prosecutor accuses
him or herself the recusal must apply to
the entire office not just the elected
or appointed prosecutor this is
consistent with best practices for
Prosecutor's Office around the country
second prosecutors should not take
advice from politically connected
friends of the accused each case should
be approached with the goal of justice
for victims while protecting the rights
of the defendant well yeah and what
they're referring to there is that Tina
Chen who is a former aide to Michelle
Obama called up the district attorney in
this
the state's attorney and asked her to
drop the case basically third when a
prosecutor seeks to resolve the case
through diversion or some other
alternative to prosecution it should be
done with an acknowledgement of
culpability on the part of the defendant
a case with the consequential effects of
mr. Smollett should not be resolved
without a finding of guilt or innocent
yes this is what we commented yesterday
if Smollett were going to be let off the
hook at least you would have to
apologize now fourth expunging mr.
Smollett record at this immediate stage
is countered to transparency law
enforcement will now not be able to
acknowledge that mr. Smollett was
indicted and charged with these horrible
crimes and the full record of what
occurred will be forever hidden from
public view finally we believe strongly
the hate crimes should be prosecuted
vigorously but the burden of proof
should not be artificially increased due
to the misguided decisions of others so
even the National Association of
District Attorney's is looking at Kim
Fox and saying what the hell is wrong
with you
how bad was Kim Fox's decision here so
bad that the FBI is now reviewing all
the circumstances and a leaked email
from the prosecutor's office shows them
scrambling scrambling to find other
cases where charges were suddenly
dropped under conditions like Smuts
here's an email that went out to the
entire State's Attorney's Office in the
aftermath of their decision quote hello
everyone we are looking for examples of
cases felony preferable where we in
exercising our discretion have entered
into verbal agreements with defense
attorneys to dismiss charges against an
offender if certain conditions were met
such as the payment of restitution
completion of community service
completion of class etc but the
defendant was not placed in a formal
diversion program please ask your ASAS
your assistant state's attorneys if they
have examples of these types of
dispositions and we will work with them
to further further to figure out on what
case it was done nobody's in trouble
we're just looking for further examples
of how we as prosecutors use our
discretion in a way that restores the
victim but causes minimal harm to the
defendant in the long term
in other words yeah we know we did
something that was completely ridiculous
here but let's see if we can find a
precedent for the completely ridiculous
thing we actually did Kim Fox is in so
much trouble that she is now denying
that she asked the court for the file to
be sealed she says it was now done by
accident it was an accident to ask the
file to be sealed
oh is that what happened Kim Fox I see
how can be
Yente fox yesterday said that the
charges were appropriate but of course
she has no precedent she has no excuse
do you think Jessie Smollett is innocent
you know I think that the charges that
were filed and again I was recused at
the time of the charges were appropriate
I believe that the outcome him having to
forfeit the $10,000 having to do
community service based on the
allegations and again the class four
felony and no background are an outcome
that we could expect with this type of
case okay just just absurd so she was
not recused now she is saying that the
charges were well done but it was
accidentally sealed this is all nonsense
the FBI should look into a president
front by the way immediately jumped into
this thing on Twitter so president Trump
has now sounds it off which you know in
these sorts of circumstances do just let
your DOJ do the work but president Trump
tweeted out about this this morning he
said quote FBI and DOJ to review the
outrageous Jessie's milette case in
Chicago it is an embarrassment to our
nation well he's right about that I
can't argue even if I'm arguing with the
with the method in which he unleashes
said comments the comments are not wrong
obviously okay in just a second we're
gonna get you president Trump president
from fighting back against his critics
on the Muller report first you're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire calm and
subscribe when you do for $9.99 a month
you get a subscription to daily wire
which is just awesome sauce you know
what that comes with it comes with two
additional hours of me a day two
additional hours yesterday we had on
Senator Steve Daines and Jordan Peterson
today we have a bunch of other special
guests who are coming on also it means
that during the break sometimes we
answer your questions also it means that
you can be part of the daily wire
backstage which airs today and I believe
4:00 p.m. Pacific time and that that is
available for all people to watch but
only subscribers can ask questions via
the beautiful and pregnant Alicia
Kraus who is spectacular and also like a
sister she's Alicia's great okay so go
check out Taylor I don't like knowles
but I like Alicia that's that's sort of
what you can take away from this go
check out daily wire com subscribe to
get all those things you get this Sunday
special which comes out on Saturday for
you if you're a subscriber with extra
content behind the paywall so many great
things that you get when you are
subscriber and with all of that the
annual
subscription the annual subscription
ninety-nine bucks a year gives you this
be very great it's in all beverage
vessels the leftist here is hot or cold
tumbler overflowing right now with tears
from the editors of The Economist
apparently because they were so upset
about me making number one on the New
York Times bestseller list with my book
that I'm now alright so let's taste
their tears actually and see how those
are very very salty it turns out so go
check that out you can get the the
leftist tears hot or cold tumbler when
you get the annual subscription make
sure that you leave us a review at
YouTube or iTunes it always helps us in
the iTunes rankings particularly we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
you
okay so president Trump is now going on
the offense against the against the
folks who suggested that he was involved
in Russian collusion
he appeared via phone with Sean Hannity
last night and there he suggested that
he was gonna release a bunch of files
now I've been saying for years that he
should I've been saying for years that
he kept complaining that the files
showed for example that the Carter page
FISA warrant was illicitly gotten and
that the the attempt to phone tap
Carter page who was a low-level foreign
policy aide on the campaign and was
suspected of being sort of a Russian
tool that that warrant was it was gotten
on the basis of bad Intel and Trump kept
complaining about that I kept saying
listen dude you couldn t classify any
time you want I think this would be good
the more we see in public view the
better here's President Trump explaining
that he's gonna release some files of
his own
I have plans to declassify and release
I have plans to absolutely release but I
have some very talented people working
for me lawyers and they really didn't
want me to do it early on a lot of
people wanted me to do it a long time
ago I'm glad I didn't do it we got a
great result without having to do it but
we will one of the reasons that my
lawyers didn't want me to do it is they
said if I do it they'll call it a form
of obstruction frankly I thought it
would be better if we held it to the end
no but at the right time we will be
absolutely released again I did the
right thing by not doing it so far okay
so yeah president from bowing that he
will now release a lot into the public
view I think that'd be good and more in
the public view is better now I do think
that it is possible for a president
Trump to overreach here I think it is
possible for the right to overreach with
the suggestion that every element of
this investigation was somehow corrupt
from the outside now I think there were
elements of this investigation that may
have been corrupt if it turns out that
James clapper was using the steel
dossier the unverified steel dossier as
the basis for this entire investigation
if it turns out that the members of the
Obama intelligence team we're using
shoddy Intel the day not bother to do
one moment of work on as the basis for
launching an investigation into an
opponent's political campaign then
that's indeed dirty stuff but I'm not
sure that we're all the way there yet
the fact is George papadopolis who was a
low-level person with the Trump campaign
did meet with a Russian cutout it is
true that in June 2016
there was a Trump Tower meeting between
a Russian lawyer who was connected to
the Russian government and Donald Trump
jr. and other members of the campaign it
is true that poem anna fort had deep
lasting ties to the Russian government
so it is possible to say a couple of
things we don't know yet I'm sure we'll
find out we will know I think in short
order whether this investigation was
started on the basis of illicit
corruption or whether it was started
honestly like a lot of investigations
and just never came to fruition and then
it turned bad because all the people who
were involved in the investigation were
personally invested in the investigation
coming up with something then it started
off as a non witch-hunt in other words
and then it gradually turned into a
witch hunt where everybody was suspected
of every crime without any proper
evidence to me that seemed more likely
because I usually attribute to stupidity
that which I usually attribute to malice
only that which I cannot attribute to
stupidity I think that as Hamlin's
raiser suggests people are generally
dumb at not malicious and so probably
the most likely scenario here is that
people were hands at Intel they got
suspicious they started an investigation
and then they convinced themselves that
Trump and his team were guilty of
something and then they started pushing
the edge then they started doing things
like issuing the card or page five
awards if it in fact it turns out that
the Carter page FISA warrant was based
solely on the Steele dossier for example
President Trump however is firmly
convinced that dirty cops started this
those are his words
here is his explained explanation of
sean hannity of how this whole entire
investigation got started there was no
collusion there was no obstruction it
was such a ridiculous thing that
happened on the other hand you know you
look at how did this start how did it
start
you had dirty cops you had people that
are bad FBI folks I know so many there
are incredible people but at the top
they were not clean and to put it mildly
and what they did to our country was a
terrible terrible thing okay so yeah
that I think could end up being an
overreach but here's the thing what
people tend to have a binary view of
subjects people people don't tend to be
able to hold two thoughts at once
cognitive dissonance isn't a thing so
people don't tend to be able to hold the
view that one the investigation came up
with nothing and yes there were corrupt
actors involved in the investigation and
to the investigation may not have been
illicitly started it was just hijack
or used by people with political
preferences who decided to violate the
oaths that they had taken because they
were so convinced of their own moral
rectitude which seems more likely to me
that that looks a lot like Peter struck
and Lisa Paige for example with that
said president Trump knows that he's got
room to run here he knows he's got
momentum and so President Trump goes
directly after James Comey and his
description of James Comey honestly I
don't think he's very far off here there
was no crime as you know you're only
allowed to do this legally if there's a
crime there was no crime they've all
admitted it Comey who's a terrible guy
Comey and mccabe and struck and Paige
the lover page and all of these people
they've admitted in testimony that there
was no crime so they started an
investigation based on no crime I mean
it's it's really that that part of it
the very unwary says was an
investigation based on no initial crime
when you launch an investigation I mean
I've worked in the DA's office when you
launch an investigation you typically do
so on the basis of an allegation if it
were proved the person would already be
in prison presumably so that's superb
when he talks about how coma me becoming
was a terrible guy you know Comey
obviously believed what he wanted to
believe again confirmation bias is a
hell of a drug so Comey appeared on NBC
Nightly News with Lester Holt last night
and he explained that he thought that
his firing was obstruction of justice
what was the basis for that belief
didn't really have one but he said in
anyway this rushar thing with Trump and
Russia is a made-up story what did you
think when you heard that I thought
that's potentially obstruction of
justice and I hope somebody is going to
look at that what he appears to be
saying is I got rid of this guy to shut
down an investigation that threatened me
he said the Russian thing and you
thought it was because of Russia because
he said so yeah but so I did yes and
that in your mind would have been
obstruction of justice no potentially
obstruction of justice and it's
complicated when it's the president of
the United States given his authority
over the executive branch but she would
certainly be irresponsible not to
explore whether that is obstruction of
justice
okay it would it be irresponsible not to
explore it because it sort of turns out
that he had the right to fire anybody he
wanted in the executive branch so long
as he was not actively impeding an
ongoing investigation which
apparently he was not because politics
tends to break down into a battle of
personalities now that Trump has been
largely vindicated on the collusion
stuff Comey is made to look a fool and
Trump has a lot of room to run here he
really does okay coming up I want to
talk about Cory Booker who appeared on
CNN last night again what you learn more
about the candidates these days is I
think what you learn about the
Democratic candidates tells you more
about where the Democratic base is than
where the candidates are because right
now what you see among the various
Democratic candidates is a dramatic
attempt to run where they think the
basis this is what all politicians do
during the primaries and the general
they runs where they think the votes are
when you watch people like Cory Booker
who used to be a quote-unquote moderate
the senator from New Jersey
there's a guy who used to work across
the aisle have conversations and people
across the aisle he used to talk someone
about school vouchers used to talk about
creative solutions to problems he wasn't
a very good mayor of New York but he
used to talk about this stuff now he is
running as the craziest leftist you can
imagine which is you know pretty wild
considering the rest of the Democratic
Party at this point so Cory Booker
appeared on CNN last night he had his
big town-hall event on CNN all the
candidates have a town hall event on CNN
and he was treated very warmly by John
lemon it seems like they're personal
friends lemon started off by teasing
Cory Booker about his veganism that's
how that's how this whole thing began
BBQ this and you're a vegan what's that
like what's that life how's that been
for you it's been a great experience for
me for a great for well being you know
when you come from a family that
literally owned a soul food restaurant
my mom and dad it may have caused some
trouble but now they understand that it
for health reasons it's a good way to go
yeah but you know you're not eating
barbecue down here right maybe putting a
little sauce on the vegetables so it's
so friendly this is the nice thing about
being on CNN as a Democrat things are so
so so friendly I don't remember them
being quite as friendly with for example
senator Ted Cruz but Cory Booker the
real point here is not by the way I just
have to note there was a point in this
interview where Don Lemon as they went
to break turn to Cory Booker and hidden
realizes Mike was still alive and he
told Cory Booker that he had done a nice
job on the answers which again is pretty
amazing
more from CNN semiotic presidential Town
Hall with senator Cory Booker lactam
Orangeburg South Carolina so make sure
he's David
[Applause]
nice job and no bias here done lemon is
very very objective in his journalism
anyway Cory Booker is a great example of
somebody who sort of speaks radicalism
as a second language in the same way
that president from seemed to speak
conservatism as a second language during
the 2016 election like he would jump to
conclusions he thought conservatives
believed even if they were wrong so
famously President Trump was asked
whether women should be punished for
abortions and the pro-life position has
generally been for decades at this point
no that's not correct
and Trump Trump Trump's right into it he
was like yeah absolutely we should
punish women for abortions cuz he
thought that's what pro-life people
thought cuz Trump didn't have a history
with the pro-life movement
Booker feels that way with the far left
and so he says things that are just
ridiculous on a regular basis so for
example here was cory booker being asked
about gun laws and just blowing it cuz
he doesn't know what he's talking about
if i am your president we are gonna
bring the fight to the nra who wants to
represent corporate gun owners core gun
corporations manufacturers more than
they want to represent the people
because this is what they're doing to
Americans they were defending loopholes
like that loophole that if a man is
convicted of beating his wife he can
find a loophole to go out and buy a gun
and murder her they are defending not
their membership but loopholes like the
loophole that says that someone on the
terrorist no-fly list in our country can
still go to a gun show and buy weapons
or there's somebody that's convicted of
a violent crime can still find a
loophole to go and buy a weapon okay so
there are so many flaws in what he is
saying right there that yeah I mean he's
not even close to the truth it is not a
loophole when someone violates a
criminal law number one also when he
talks about the the laws regarding guns
he's just not correct about them I mean
he just says things that are eminently
untrue Dana lash was a spokesperson for
the National Rifle Association went
directly at him she said first of all
the NRA is is not an actual government
organization the NRA represents everyday
Americans also federal law bars domestic
abusers from buying or possessing guns
so what the hell are you talking about
and Booker did this the whole interview
right here here's Booker explaining that
he would rather hang out with a nice
atheist than a mean religious person as
though religious people everywhere
somehow it would
rather hang out with evil religious
people than hang out with nice atheists
I just want to say up front that I'm a
person often says it before you tell me
about your religion show it to me and
how you treat other people in a church
with my mom taught Sunday School and
I'll never forget learning that verse
that faith without works is dead and and
I'll tell you what I feel like I'm in
church right now and I'll tell you what
this is what often bother I would rather
hang out with a nice atheist and a mean
Christian any day of the week I love
that that receives a giant round of
applause you know who else would rather
do that every Christian I know you know
you know why because we don't like mean
people like religious people generally
I'm an Orthodox Jew we're not big on the
mean people because mean people are
unlikable inherently and the sort of
pandering is so absurd the the worst
pandering though was Cory Booker on
jussie Smollett so he's asked about
Jesse Smollett and somehow he
manipulates this does Spartacus into an
attack on the political right which is a
weird thing to do since Jesse Smollett
faked a hate crime I don't know all the
details in the prosecutors decision I
know that's gonna come out but what we
got to know is that this is happening in
a larger context where hate crimes in
this country or arise where white
supremacists violence is on the rise in
fact if you look at the majority of
terrorist acts since 9/11 the majority
of them have been done by homegrown
right-wing extremist groups and the
majority of those have been white
supremacist groups what does that have
to do with Jesse smut how do we get from
the question which was was the decision
to drop charges against Smollett a
whitewash how do we get from that to the
majority of terrorist attacks in the
United States have been by white
supremacist groups I mean there's truth
to that statement although the majority
of dead from terrorist attacks in the
United States particularly since 2001 if
you include 2001 are in radical Islamic
terror attacks but with that said what
is that such a non sequitur what does
that have to do with anything
so Jesse Smollett lied about a hate
crime and Cory Booker's response is to
immediately launch into an attack on
white supremacist like I'm fine with the
attack on white supremacists enjoy but I
just want to know why that has anything
to do with letting jussie Smollett off
the hook this is why cory booker is not
a very good candidate and this is why
cory booker is inevitable
going to fall apart because it turns out
that he like to many other Democrats is
simply an empty vessel for what he
thinks the base wants rather than a
representative of something actual and
real it's one of the reasons by the way
why Peabody judge is actually picking up
ground on bethe O'Rourke if you look at
the Google searches but a judge is
suddenly picking up steam that's cuz
he's more substantive than bethe
O'Rourke and at a certain point even
even Democratic members of the base are
gonna want something a little more
substantive than they've been offered so
far okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like one of the fun things about
the launch of my number one New York
Times bestselling book the right side of
history just patting myself on the back
right there and you cuz you bought it
it's really cuz of you is that I have to
sign something like fifteen to twenty
thousand copies of the book now and that
means that every night I have to put on
a movie and then just sign in sign in
sign in sign well the other night I was
looking for something to watch and I
came across a movie on Amazon Prime
called trans-siberian which I missed at
the time it is Woody Harrelson and Ben
Kingsley Ben Kingsley is one of my
favorite actors the movie is basically a
potboiler
about a couple who are on a train with
another couple and the other couple
turns out may or may not be criminals
the the movie is called trans-siberian
here's a little bit of a preview
[Music]
next stop Russia come on our new cabin
mates where'd they come from he said
that they were eating in Japan do you
think it's obvious we're American this
is a gringo he's a detective the bad
guys people who look innocent but
they're really not they add special
chemical to heroin molded into objects
they pay much money for this movie is
good Woody Harrelson is is really good
in it
and the whole movie is is worth watching
it's a really kind of tight little
thriller so worth picking up if you're
looking for something to watch Annette
trans-siberian on Amazon Prime ok time
for a couple of things that I hate so it
turns out that ABC's The View is a
complete crazy house there's a new book
out called ladies who punch the
explosive inside story of the view is
written by Ramin setsuna the New York
bureau chief of variety it has a lot of
details about the show they sat down for
everyone except for Elisabeth Hasselbeck
and Whoopi Goldberg there's a bunch of
stuff in there that is not great for the
view according to The Huffington Post
review of the book Barbara Walters the
founder of the view is portrayed as a
leader who understandably held too tight
grip on the show but was also deeply
egomaniacal and threatened by women who
are more popular namely Joy Behar and
Rosie O'Donnell the book also alleges
she actively participated in undermining
current and former co-host by leaking
embarrassing information to the press
apparently she did this specifically
with Rosie O'Donnell she specifically
went after Rosie O'Donnell and and
dictated that when Rosie O'Donnell's
book came out that there be a bunch of
bad stuff that come about Rosie
O'Donnell in the press apparently there
was a massive behind-the-scenes clash
between
Rosie O'Donnell and Marc Gentile the
show's director O'Donnell says she took
issue with Gentile because of his
incompetence insiders at the view told
Satuday that they believe O'Donnell
targeted Gentile because he once
rejected her offer to poach him from the
view when she was trying to do her own
daytime talk show in the book O'Donnell
shared a story of when she walked into a
meeting at the view and asked a group of
staffers is this mark Marx Gentiles baby
a woman producer
the show is holding a baby in her arms
according to city dead the producer who
Masuda has not named in the book had
been having an affair with Gentile who
was married
the affair was an open secret among the
staff and Walters was aware of it the
producer didn't directly report to
Gentile but at the view this was not
considered in an issue so all sorts of
details about it turns out guys that
Hollywood is a terrible place filled
with bad people who do bad things I know
hard to imagine in other Hollywood news
good news Chris Evans the guy who plays
Captain America and has I'm in the
Battle of the Chris's you know Chris
Pine Chris Pratt they're a bunch of
they're a bunch of good Chris's I do not
think that Chris Evans is one of them I
do not think he's a very good actor and
that is not merely because he said back
in 2013 that he genuinely disliked me
even though I have no idea if he's a
nice guy or not I'm an Imagine he's not
at this point
he is founding a new political website
because that's what we need it is called
a starting point the mission to create
informed responsible empathetic citizens
yeah that's gonna be great that's what
we need we need Chris Evans sounding off
about politics he knows as much about
politics as I know about memorizing
script which is to say virtually nothing
also Chris Evans in his new in his new
role as Ombudsman of an important
journalistic outlet suggested that he
could no longer root for Tom Brady he
said quote I really hope he's not a
trump supporter
I'm just hoping he's one of those guys
that may be supporting him and now
regrets it maybe he thought it was gonna
be different and even that bothers me
but maybe there's a chance he now just
thinks Trump's an absolute dumb bleep
which he is if he doesn't if he's still
on that Trump train I might have to cut
ties it's really tough so he's cutting
ties with Tom Brady because Tom Brady
supports a different political candidate
he seems like a perfect candidate to run
a journalistic outlet we need another
outlet that is wildly left and
inaccurate about their coverage I think
that would be good that's probably the
best all righty so we will be back here
later today with two additional hours
plus we have an episode of daily wire
backstage this is why you should
subscribe also go pick up a copy of my
number-one New York Times best-selling
book the right side of history labeled
alt-right by The Economist by the way
breaking news The Economist has now
issued an apology thank you it says the
this article has been changed a previous
version mistakenly described mr. Shapiro
as an outright sage and a pop idol of
the alt-right in fact he's been strongly
critical of the alt-right movement we
apologize
well thanks thanks appreciate it
all right we'll be back here later today
with two more hours I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show it's going to
take some time before we understand the
full effects of the end of the Muller
investigation I think it showed not only
the corruption of the mainstream media
but the corruption of the Obama
administration and even more than that
it shows the failure of the elites in
this country to hold up their
self-imposed status I'm Andrew Clavin
that's on the Andrew Clavin show